[Music]
let's go to
samantha in chicago what's up samantha
hey how are you just rocking onto the
brick of dawn how about you
awesome doing great excellent so what's
up
all right so my husband's currently in a
graduate program to become a christ a
christian licensed professional
counselor so i wanted to call in and get
your perspective um more specifically i
haven't heard of specializing oh almost
like i haven't heard of so he is he
getting his
lpc
yeah he's getting his lpc at a christian
university with the plan to specialize
in drug and alcohol recovery at a
christian facility wherever that's going
to be so he he
he's getting he's going to become a
licensed counselor and he happens to be
a person of faith
yeah and actually through as he's going
through the program he's realizing um
more and more
while
the whole world needs help it will be
difficult for him to kind of
intertwine jesus and and that part into
the spiritual healing of people in kind
of secular institutions so he's kind of
targeting specifically drug and alcohol
recovery because um that's part of his
testimony how he came to christ as well
as um christian organizations so that's
kind of
what he's working towards and i'm
totally supportive of that and when we
met you know he was he was
in his undergrad for psychology and
counseling and um
he was kind of focusing more towards uh
counseling men so he went through a
christian christian recovery program
that was men only and he's planning to
intern at that
place as well okay but as we're we got
married a year ago and and this is kind
of um
i've been christian three years he's
been christian six years where our first
relationship since being christian so
trying to apply things from the bible
and marriage and and uh boundaries with
opposite sex has been uh just a
challenge in a lot of different areas so
when it comes to friendships and
even i work in finance so the nature of
my job is not spiritually or emotionally
intimate but in any case if i have
meetings or one-on-one um with men or
anything like that it's it's all
transparent you know that's the type of
stuff that we can talk about so
some of my struggles or concerns with if
he does decide to also counsel women
it's just i have a lack of comfort with
that because
generally counseling is private it's
it's one-to-one often behind closed
doors and definitely confidential
you know there's
there's a lot of intimate topics that
are discussed i myself am in counseling
and so a t so we we know what kind of
things are
talked about and while i do understand
it's one way it's client to counselor
honestly i just don't really like the
idea of a woman another woman sharing
their hearts and soul with my husband
and kind of believe that's reserved for
marriage um
now i do trust him
but i do know that we're sinners at
heart and
for me it's just kind of it just doesn't
feel safe like we're putting in good
boundaries or safeguarding when there
are great options to just counsel men
and
hold on hold on
let me break in here let me break in
here
um so i'm gonna say this as kindly as i
can but as directly as i can okay
your marriage is not safe right now
okay
um
you have some very
deep
trust challenges with the person either
with yourself or the person you're
married to
and
whether you're
i don't care what your faith persuasion
is
i don't care
what your
professions are
you all need to get together asap
and deal with the trust issues
whether you're bringing them to the
table and you've been hurt in the past
or you've made bad decisions in the past
or this guy has
made bad decisions in his past etc
a counselor is
like a surgeon
like a doctor
like a plumber they are trained
professional
and part of the training is
how to remain objective how to be honest
with yourself how to sit in consulting
how to fill in the blank is counseling
intimate you better believe it is
but is there a difference between that
relational intimacy that happens in a
professional setting
in sexual intimacy there better be or
that person shouldn't be a therapist
yeah yeah and so and i know just trust
issues i know i have that so i'm aware
and i'm an individual counseling
associate and we we are also in marriage
counseling so we're covering all the
bases and ultimately it's
gonna be prayers with god so actually
what i'm doing and i've sought this out
with other um like a woman professional
counselor and ask this question too
because what i want to do is to get
other perspectives that are different
than my own
more objective so the i think that
besides the trust issues which
for sure is is ongoing and for me it's
not just like um the counseling jump we
just have
or myself uh personally just issues with
when it comes to op this is sex but the
the one
aspect that
i really struggle with and i i think it
is outside of the trust issue is
understanding that it is a profession
and there's ethics and standards and
everything that counselors abide by
to me it's different than being a
plumber or a surgeon that is doing
surgery because this is like emotional
and spiritual intimacy
that another woman is sharing but the
biggest part of that is
the confidential nature of counseling so
if i'm experiencing um you know
emotionally intimate conversations with
another man in whatever setting or i'm
going to male doctor these are all
meetings and
meetings that i could share with my
husband it's not something that he can't
know about or he can't know about
you're getting exactly you're you're
making my point for me this has nothing
to do with counseling
at all
this has to do with the fact that your
husband's gonna have a part of his life
that you won't have access to and
something about that makes you crazy
yes exactly and so that that is
your
challenge to work through
and this is
you've got to be okay with it i know but
when it comes to
you know being a christian and the
covenant and sacredness and transparency
of marriage to me it feels like okay
we're supposed to be one we're supposed
to just be in each other's lives and
total transparency between the two of us
and then then there's this major part of
his life that he'll be spending you know
more time in because
work is generally more time than with
family and it's something that i can't
have access to because of the nature of
the job and to me that it feels like a
violation to
marriage
and so what you're conflating in a
dangerous way
is
open access
and trust
trust is
faith is i'm leaning into you and you're
leaning into me
and about the things
that you want to share with me
i trust that you're honoring this
relationship
i trust that you're honoring me
so let's imagine you have some
rambunctious dream
about an ex-boyfriend
do you feel like that you're violating
your husband's trust if you don't wake
him up in the middle of the night and
tell him about what you just dreamt
or is there some stuff you go oh
i'm gonna hang on to that one
and if
i'm just
this you are using faith
you are using your christian beliefs
you are using this idea of intimacy in
marriage
and one with somebody else
as an excuse to read his diary
as an excuse to get into his client's
folders
and this is you're conflating two things
that have no business being together
it's dishonoring
it is unethical it's wrong
to get into somebody else's life if they
haven't invited you in
and in the profession that your husband
is choosing they have invited him into
that
and you mentioned the doctor but you
mentioned on the other side of it
meaning
you do if you go have a doctor visit
um with a male doctor you can come go
around and tell everybody
he cannot
he can't go home to his family and say
well i saw so-and-so without her shirt
on today here's what it looked like
here's this here's it can't do that
that's your privacy
and so you want one side of the
teeter-totter but you expect the other
and it doesn't work like that
yeah and so what i'm telling you is a
there is some wisdom
you're new at this like your faith is
young your faith is new and you are
going all in on it and i honor that good
for you
and it sounds like you love this guy so
so much
that you want to share dna i mean you
want to line your souls up together
right
i almost said you want to share dna and
then i realized that's probably not the
right way to say that um well you know
if we have a kid i guess it's very
technically true but you want to
mirror
at the at the genetic level and you
can't
and so the piece you have to make is
what does trust look like what does
faith in somebody else look like
when i can't know everything that my
friend is love
yeah and i wonder um from your
perspective with counseling probably
anyone regardless of gender
just just high level do you have some
like
ideas of what are some good boundaries
like some some counselors have told me
like they don't share their personal
number you know they don't take calls
outside of work hours but
the thing i was thinking is like
something that could help me besides
obviously individual counseling and
continuing
prayer with god is
is healthy boundaries but it's hard to
know what's healthy right now because of
just all the other stuff that i'm
dealing with yeah and you are trying to
make his boundaries for him his
professional boundaries for him because
you're uncomfortable
yeah
and
again you are getting into somebody
else's head
and thinking their thoughts for them and
then you are trying to respond to those
thoughts that haven't even been thought
yet
and you're wearing yourself out
yeah you're exhausting yourself
and you're trying to duct tape this all
together through a young new faith
and it's becoming it's it's slowly
pulling you underwater
to the point that you are wondering if
he should even be doing what he wants to
be doing with his life
yeah yeah and you come at him with
verses and chapters
and
when he's trying to do an assignment or
doing his practicum or doing whatever
and
what i'm telling you is your marriage
is on really shaky ground
yeah
and so the question is not
are there good boundaries and practices
absolutely that people have do different
therapists have different roles yes some
are super firm
some are more open access like i am your
therapist you can reach me at this time
i think that's dangerous but
not and not for sexuality stuff even
though that's an issue
let me be super clear with you
counselors sleep with their clients it
happens yeah and that is you will get
your license taken away and you will
never be able to
um be in somebody's intimate life again
and that should be that way
anyone who ever sleeps with a client
should immediately be stripped of their
license period
and who kisses a client hold hands with
i mean there is no romance in that
setting
right right
if you tell your husband i'm
uncomfortable these things you're
allowed to do that you're allowed to
feel those things and then he's gonna
have a choice
so i don't wanna dishonor your feelings
but i wanna tell you that the feelings
you have are deeper than just this
profession
because what's gonna happen is he's
gonna quit and he's gonna go be a
plumber
and then you're gonna say
where are you going to so-and-so's house
to fix the dishwasher he's like yeah i
just got some client her name is susan
and you're going to say was there going
to be any men there
and you'll say i don't know i'm just
going to fix the dishwasher this address
so there's just going to be a woman
there and then that's going to make it
bananas yeah like they'll always be
something always be something
yeah that's a good point and whether
it's a lawn business or a restaurant
when you took that woman's cash did you
touch your hand like it's always gonna
be a thing
yeah and so at some point when you are
married when you love somebody
i have to trust that my wife had an
experience today and she chose not to
tell me for a reason
i have to trust that
it may be that whenever she tells me
about some guy that was rude to her i
bow up like oh i'm going to go fight him
or i'm going to call him or i'll let him
know and she doesn't want to deal with
me maybe i've made her unsafe
or maybe she's a big
grown-up grown woman
and she she's not big by the way i'd
realize i'm gonna get in trouble for
that she is a grown-up she's a grown
woman
and she can decide whether you know i
mean that's her choice
and there's certain things i've said hey
if this happens please let me know and
she then said i'm gonna honor you by
doing that or that violates my
boundaries and i'm not comfortable with
that and then we negotiate those things
but somewhere in your core honey you
have a
major
major chasm with trust
and i don't know if it's from your
childhood i don't know it's from your
your previous romantic relationships but
it is heavy and you're trying to solve
it by knowing every second of every
moment of every
interaction with your husband and you're
gonna make yourself nuts
and you're gonna burn the relationship
to the ground
and so as you move forward with trust as
you move forward yes he has to have
professional boundaries that's between
him and his counseling supervisor
yes there's going to be things of of
comfort if he's cheated on you if he
comes home and he's like man this woman
was talking about sex and it kind of
turned me on he probably shouldn't be a
therapist
but you are allowed to say hey these
things make me uncomfortable right now
i'm not comfortable with you
uh counseling xyz that's fair had those
conversations
but i want you to go deeper because you
got to deal with your trust issues and
this is about your marriages isn't about
his job right now the job y'all could
talk about later
i want you all to deal with the trust
issues here because you're worth
being able to breathe and right now you
can't breathe
trust is so so hard especially when it's
been broken
but you can't heal it you've got to be
intentional about dealing with that not
the peripheral issues deal with the
trust